it was this meeting between Xi Jinping
and Anthony Albanese on the sidelines of
the G20 Summit in Indonesia in November
that indicated relations between
Australia and China were out of the
Diplomatic deep freeze two years after
Beijing placed an unofficial ban on
Australian Lobster coal barley wine and
beef industry leaders are optimistic The
Next Step will be the lifting of those
trade restrictions we'd like to get it
back there if we could live lobster to
China represented at 98 of our trade for
lobster loans plenty of comment going on
about China opening up and particularly
with the trade relations improving
Australia used to be the second largest
supplier of coal to China that ground to
a halt in 2020 and the former prime
minister Scott Morrison demanded an
independent investigation into the
origins of the Coronavirus
now in a partial resumption of Trade
four major Chinese companies including
power generators and one steel mill have
been cleared to import Australian coal
yes we welcome the opportunity and we're
optimistic that China will open its its
Imports to us again but we have
Diversified away from China and so it
will be very competitive in terms of
being able to supply any uh any orders
into China
tariffs and bands imposed by Beijing
have impacted Australian exports worth
14 billion dollars a year actions that
are now before the World Trade
Organization Canberra has indicated it
would be willing to reconsider its case
if Beijing lifts restrictions
we shouldn't be overconfident we
shouldn't be complacent we should
continue to try to diversify our trade
base and the like because the
geopolitical problems with China aren't
going to go away in the short term
and let's say the rebuilding of
political trust will also take time
trade Minister John Farrell will meet
his Chinese counterpart virtually in
coming weeks it's the latest sign of
efforts to try and stabilize what has
been a turbulent relationship with
Australia's largest trading partner the
ministerial meeting will be the first in
more than three years Sarah Clark Al
Jazeera Brisbane